بعد عام واحد من اطلاقها في الرياض انطلقت
في شرم الشيخ النسخه الثانيه من مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء وزيرو طاقه السعوديه
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان افتتح
الفعاليات من خلال استعراض ما انجزته
المملكه وما تنوي استكماله من مشاريع
للوصول الى الحياد الكربوني بحلول العام
2060 وربما قبل هذا التاريخ والانتقال
التدريجي الى الاقتصاد الاخضر كوسيله
لتحقيق التنميه المستدامه مشتركه نحن
ملتزمون بتقليل الانبعاثات الكربونيه
بمقدار
280 مليون طن واثق اننا سنكون قادرين على
الوفاء بذلك ولقد ذكرت منذ وقت طويل اننا
نخطط ونهدف لتوليد 50% من الكهرباء من
الطاقه المتجدده وقد تم بالفعل توليده 400
ميجاوات من الطاقه النظيفه حيث تم التقليص
الانبعاثات الكربونيه بنحو مليون طن
النسخه الثانيه شهيده استع العديدي من
المشاريع والافكار التي تشارك فيها مجموعه
من الوزارات والمؤسسات اهم المكاتب احنا
عندنا اليوم هذا الطريق واضح لزراعه 600
مليون من الاشعار من هذا العشره مليار
احنا بدانا في ذلك وانجزنا عشرات الملايين
هذا مزروعه موجوده على الارض وفيما يخص
600 مليون همم هي موجوده
تخطيط المدن اول شيء احنا مرتبطين همم
اتفاقيه همم وضعها سمو ولي العهد اننا رفع
ال- همم الطموح والمؤشرات والمعايير بحيث
اننا نكون مرتبطين باهداف الاس دي جي اللي
هي الاستدامه البيئيه واستلام الصديقات
همم وجودنا في هذه مركز همم او اهداف الاس
دي جي اللي اطلقه الامم المتحده عام 2015
كان يركز كثير على همم وضع مواصفات في
التخطيط همم
للمناطق الحضريه واحنا التزمنا فيها هذه
معايير التي وضعت الان في جميع تخطيطنا
المكان وتخطيط المجمعات الحضريه ستساعدنا
في تحقيق الاقتصاديات المطلوبه وجعل مدن
اكثر استدامه القطاع الخاص السعودي شارك
بكثافه من خلال مجموعه متنوعه من المشاريع
التي شكلت مزيجا من مكافحه التصحر
والتجشير واعاده تدوير النفايات وغيرها من
المبادرات المنصه تطيح للمجتمع لزراعه
الاشجار اون لاين في اقل من دقيقه اي
مواطن صغير كبير يبقى يزرع شجره اليوم بكل
سهوله جدا يدخل منصه نباتك يختار الشجره
يختار الموقع ويزرع اليوم 95% من النفايات
تذهب الى المراجل المبادره تقول العكس
تماما نبغى
94% يعاد تدويرها جدير بالذكر ان مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء تم اطلاقها نهايه العام
2021 من قبل ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان وتسعى للوصول الى الحياد الصفري
للانبعاث الكربوني من خلال الاقتصاد
الدائري الكربوني ويبقى الاجماع بان
النسخه الثانيه من مبادره السعوديه
الخضراء قد نجحت في لفت الانظار من خلال
حجم الافكار والمشاريع التي تم طرحها من
خلال هذه النسخه من قمه كوب 27 في شرم
الشيخ احمد عثمان العربيه شرم الشيخ